everybody has a different talent and the
reason we're all so messed up is because
you're looking at everybody else's
Talent
I don't fear anything but I'll worry
about everything and the day you stop
worrying in good times the paddle will
get your behind somebody taught me a
long time ago a very valuable lesson
which is want to be happy
build a life not just the business hey
it's Evan Carmichael and this channel is
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you to you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how billionaires think
and how you can apply their thought
process to your business okay let's kick
it off with thought number one focus on
service with Oprah Winfrey everybody has
a different talent and the reason we're
all so messed up is because you're
looking at everybody else's talent and
wishing you had some of their talent all
the energy that you spend thinking about
wishing about being jealous of envious
of anybody else is energy that you're
not only putting out it's going to come
back to you negatively but you're taking
that away from you
all your energy should be forced on what
do I have to offer what do I have to
give how can I be used in service
because dr. King's message of not
everybody can be famous but everybody
can be great because greatness is
determined by service and there is not a
job in here that you can do that you
don't switch the paradigm to service and
not make that job more fulfilling I
don't care what the job is if you say
I'm a singer I'm a dancer I'm an artist
I'm a teacher I'm a nurse I'm a doctor
I'm a janitor I'm a clerk about if you
say if I look at this from how do I use
this in service to something bigger than
myself no longer becomes a job
it becomes an offering to the world
thought number two do the right things
with Steve Jobs somebody taught me a
long time ago a very valuable lesson
which is if you do the right things on
the top line the bottom line will follow
and what they meant by that was if you
get the right strategy if you have the
right people and if you have the right
whole trick culture at your company
you'll do the right products you'll do
the right marketing you'll do the right
things logistically in a manufacturing
and distribution and if you do all those
things right the bottom line will follow
thought number three change yourself
with Jack Ma when I said the business
because it's so difficult to be a small
business owner in China it took me five
months to bottom five hundred dollars
and still fit no chance and it is it is
and I have no any idea about how to run
a business and I when I go to register
company called Internet the register
officer said no there's no such a word
into native dictionary talking register
and Internet so I say you have to
register another name thing it wasn't
what's the name is a computer consulting
firm and I have no idea at what is
computed so my first company's pounds of
hope because computer consulting firm
it was tough was not know anything but
enough technology without knowing
anything but a computer in the past of
15 years been working I call myself like
a blind man riding on the back of the
blind tigers those
Spurs riding horses they all fell we
survived because we worried by the
future would believe the future we
change ourselves we know completely
honest also if you want to have more
self love and confidence check out my
254 series they're free
the link to join are in the description
below they bought stolen property and
they tried to extort you
I always did everything back ass half
words you know I like to challenge
myself from day one I just I never tried
to hide that I was the girl in my
apartment with the red backpack thought
number four is fear nothing with Tillman
Fertitta tell people your your concept
of the paddle well there's a paddle for
everybody's ass we all know that and
every day you just get up and I don't
fear anything but I'll worry about
everything and the day you stop worrying
in good times the paddle will get your
behind and and and so his greatest
things are in life I know you're only a
few steps or a few incidents away from
something bad happened and you can never
forget it did you have fear as a kid and
you just got into enough business
scuffles that you figured your way
through things or have you always been
fearless I'm pretty fearless but I do
worry about everything but you know once
again you know the book and this is why
Harper's asked me to write the book
because of all my Tillman isms you got
to know what you know when what you
don't know and and I knew that I
understood business now don't ask me to
you know go win an Emmy I took guitar
lessons for four years and I still
struggle playing the guitar I can't draw
a stick person very good but I knew that
I understood business so I know what I
know and I know how to do due diligence
on a deal I don't worry about making a
bad deal because I feel like that's what
I know
so no fear when it comes to that thought
number five be different with Mark Cuban
you talked about companies having a UK
unique advantage can you speak more on
that for me please sure I mean what is
it that that a customer can get from you
that they can't get from anybody else
and you have to be very careful with
that too when I just talked about lying
to yourself as an entrepreneur because
often will say well it's just
like uber but it has pink cars uber
doesn't have pink cars that that's a
difference without a distinction right
lots of times people get confused
between what's a product and what's a
feature pink uber cars that's a feature
that's not a unique product excuse me so
you have to know what it is that you do
that is so unique people the people your
potential customers say whoa I did not
know that
as opposed to well let me go tell over
that they should probably add pink cars
because whenever you're competing with
them you know all of you are going to
compete with the Amazon at some point if
you're not already just a reality and so
you've got to understand when Amazon
starts looking at my customer base what
is it that I can convey to them that
makes me unique and that's that's what I
meant by a unique difference thought
number six is learned from your mistakes
with Ray Dalio
so 19 a 1979 80 81 I calculated that
American banks had lent a lot more money
to emerging countries than those
countries are going to get payback and I
anticipated that there would be a debt
crisis and with that an economic crisis
so that was my thinking and August 1982
Mexico defaulted on its debt and a
number of countries followed and so
because I said that I got a lot of
attention about that and I thought that
was going to be producing a bear market
in stocks and I could not have been more
wrong August 1982 was the exact bottom
in the stock market and I was wrong and
as a result of that let's take my 8
employees or I had to let them go I lost
money for myself I lost money for and I
had to borrow $4,000 from my dad it was
the most painful one of the most painful
experiences but it was one of the best
experiences that ever happened to me in
my life because it it changed my
perspective about decision making if
made it may give me the humility that I
needed and fear of being wrong
in my decisions while I was able to
maintain my aggressiveness so it changed
my whole approach to decision-making and
thought number seven the last time
before our very special bonus clip is
protect your ideas with Sara Blakely I
didn't tell anybody my idea for one
whole year and it's very important to
tell the people that can help move your
idea forward but I didn't share it for
validation purposes and no one had
shared that with me it was sort of a gut
feeling but one you know ideas are the
most vulnerable in their infancy the
moment you have them and this is the
moment that we always want to turn to a
friend a co-worker a husband and tell
somebody the idea well the minute you
tell somebody the idea ego has to get
involved and then you end up spending
all of your time defending it and
explaining it rather than pursuing it so
I feel like more than anything the
reason why I'm not still selling fax
machines is because I kept it a secret
for one whole year and all my friends
and family can tell you all I would ever
they would say is theirs working on some
crazy invention we don't know what it is
and after one year I signed them all
down I said okay guys it's footless
pantyhose I mean you should've seen
their faces like and out of love and
concern I heard you know if it's such a
good idea why isn't somebody else done
it and sweetie if it is such a good idea
you'd use your life savings and the big
guys might knock you out of the water in
six months and until I'd invested this
much of myself in this I think if I had
heard that a year ago when I cut the
feet out of my pantyhose that day I'd
still be selling fax machines now we got
a special bonus cut for Moore and
Buffett on how to turn your failure into
a plus that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions let's go
from just watching a video to taking
action here we go
question number one how can you focus on
service this week number two where do
you need to change yourself and number
three how are you going to be different
and if you made it this far in the video
you're still watching and you commit to
taking action after watching this video
I want to celebrate you give me a
hashtag believe down the video
how do you turn failure and go plus and
it's true when I was in the university
Nebraska one day I was reading the daily
Nebraskan and it said in room 303
o'clock that will be this panel of three
professors here at the University and
they're going to award the Nathan gold
scholarship I don't know whether you
still you still have it around and at
the time it said it would give you five
hundred dollars to go to the graduate
school of your choice I don't know
whether it's change in the mountain but
that that was it so I read this and I
went there for this room at three
o'clock that day or whatever it was and
I walked in the room and there were the
professors and I was the only student
that showed up I mean really got to him
I mean anything they were stuck they you
know they kept waiting and looking at
their watch and hoping there'll be more
candidates but there no one came in so I
won $500 budget by default and
those are usually my biggest triumphs
when nobody else shows up and so here I
was I had $500 to go toward any it
wasn't it was limited as any any
graduate school for a master's degree so
I applied to Harvard my dad wanted me to
and i shortly heard from harvard and
they said go to chicago and meet this
fellow running that who interviews
applicants from the Midwest so I got on
the train and that's what she did in
those days and I spent on 10 hours on
the Burlington going to Chicago then I
transferred to another little inner
urban train to go up to this country day
school where this fellow was the
headmaster and he was the big
interviewer for Harvard and I got there
and after about 10 minutes he he said
better think about something else
you know he come back later on I was I
was 19 at the time and I looked about 12
you know and and I and I acted about 8
it was not a great combination but so he
said forget it so I spent a little in
urban train back to Chicago and I took
the 10-hour train back to Omaha all the
time I think you know what do I tell my
parents you know it's kind of
embarrassing but it was it was the
luckiest thing ever happened to me
I because if I'd gone to Harvard I would
have gone to a two-year business school
I instead applied to Columbia where I
could graduate in one year and get a
masters degree luckily that by the
accident of it and being in the Nebraska
National Guard which did not get called
up for the Korean War I missed going in
the Korean War I I got to meet Ben
Graham and which had an enormous effect
on me subsequently and I probably got my
wife that way because she was going to
Northwestern and I was able to put on
sort of a full-court press because I got
out in one year and otherwise she'd
she'd have met some other guy I mean I
got her before the competition showed up
and
so it worked out wonderfully it couldn't
have worked out better and that's been
that's been my life basically I mean
that the things you know you will get
some disappointments you know but the
future is what counts be fun if I knew
every decision I was going to make was
gonna be perfect it would not be as much
fun he liked playing golf and knowing
you're gonna hit a hole-in-one on every
hole you wouldn't play golf if every
time you got out of T you just took a
swing of the ball ended up in the hole
yeah be fun for a few days you get get
on TV but it the game would not be any
fun so its failure you know and I
wouldn't even consider them failures but
there are mistakes you whatever you want
us to call it they're part of the game
and in the end you know you go on and
and we've made plenty of mistakes in
business we'll make money more and then
you know the Babe Ruth and you know for
a long time it subsequently we got
eclipsed by a few fellows but he held
the record for strikeouts and also the
held the record for home runs in his
eyes by baseball player until the modern
era came along and so it's it's part of
the game if you take big swings you know
you it may you may you're gonna miss
some times
if you want to see another amazing video
on how billionaires think check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there so after four or five
years of begging people to build tunnels
and still no tunnels I was like okay I
wanna build a tunnel